you'll enter a real serious thing but
you did you did forgive the Walmart
drivers I forgave him and I'm not even
mad at him no more but you know who is
mad at him
no I'm not mad at him I forgave him but
you know who is mad am all my white
neighbors yeah you moved into a
different neighborhood now yeah yeah I
was driving my Lamborghini the other day
in there and y'all might do say mister
how fast is she gone sort of drivers
[ __ ] like a pimp how fast you go in your
Lamborghini 30 miles per hour say bye
neighbor you can see I don't do a speed
speed it's for kids yeah when you were
I'll go slow like I'm checking track now
when you were in the hospital a lot of
family visit you there oh yeah my family
came everybody came everybody showed up
just to tell me they loved me except for
my grandmother she was there but she
just like every other old black woman or
she care about his education so I said
grandma I made it I'm alive she said
good now you go back get your GED
I said as a grandma I was on dirtying
rods she's a fragile GD who did it on 60
rock told me about said your uncle came
and visited you right yeah but he's
crazy he tried to steal my heart monitor
and sell it to another hospital and
that's what I went to the FDR and I
wrote Krakens back when Apple
[Laughter]